God gave John Paul the strength
to be an unforgettable human being.
Let us give thanks
for the joy he spread his whole life long.
Everything bad that could have happened
has happened.
Except that.
Who knows if there’s foul play here but if there is
the culprit usually shows up at the funeral.
Alright, Columbo.
Mclauchlan and Sons
We’re handling John Paul’s life insurance policy.
Were you very close?
Yeah,  he was our brother in law.
My condolences Mrs. Winns.
Oh egg and onion!
It’s like you knew I was coming.
Did ya?
She can’t find out what we did.
Do you like it?
Get a grip of yourself!
I know you don’t think he’s a good man!
Families they're
complex.
I’m warning you.
She doesn’t respect you
because you’re weak.
She wasn’t always like that
he’s sucking the life out of her
Well we’ll just have to wait
until he dies of cancer or something.
Why not give nature a helping hand?
You’re talking about taking a man’s life!
Not a man
that monster!
That’s
demented.
You’re going to land yourselves and me in jail!
I’m hungry are you?
No!
There’s no evidence
we should be looking for fraud
Murder is fraud
when there’s a life policy to pay up
It’s not happening
It was one moment of madness
Two moments of madness
You’re vile
do you know that
You can’t just explode a man
He thinks someone is trying to kill him
That's insane!